UNBELIEVABLE.
MARK STEYN, THANK YOU FOR
CHRONICLING THIS REVOLUTION
WITH US.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS A LOT, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT WE
TELLING YOU ABOUT A SERIES
OF BLOG POSTS APPARENTLY
WRITTEN BY MSNBC WEEKEND
ANCHOR JOY REID MORE THAN A
DECADE AGO.
AT THE TIME REID WAS NOT THE
HUMOROUS PROGRESSIVE ROBOT
YOU KNOW SO WELL TODAY.
AT THE TIME HER VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION WERE SOME WHERE
TO THE RIGHT OF DONALD TRUMP
SINCE MASS IMMIGRATION HURTS
POOR PEOPLE THE MOST.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A NEW SET OF
ANTIQUE JOY REID BLOG POST
UNCOVERED BY BUZZFEED.
ONE TOAST ENTITLED BAGHDAD
JOHN STRIKES AGAIN.
REID SHARED AN IMAGE OF JOHN
MCCAIN'S FACE SUPER IMPOSED
ONTO THE BODY OF THE
VIRGINIA TECH MASS SHOOTER.
COULDN'T DO THAT TODAY.
REID ALSO PROMOTED A 9/11
CONSPIRACY DOCUMENTARY.
SHE ATTACKS CONGRESSMAN
BARNEY FRANK OF
MASSACHUSETTS FOR THE CRIME
OF BEING GAY AND SHE WROTE A
SIR IS APARTICULAR CALL
PLACE ABOUT TONY BLAIR'S SON
VISITING BATHHOUSES IN THE
U.S.
SPICY.
REID PREVIOUSLY CLAIMED HER
BLOG HAD BEEN RETROACTIVELY
HACKED BY UNSEEN SOMEBODY
HACKED BY UNSEEN SABEBODY
HACKED BY UNSEEN SABOTODY
HACKED BY UNSEEN SABOTEUY
HACKED BY UNSEEN SABOTEURS
PROBABLY RUSSIAN AGENTS.
IT WAS IS CERTAINLY A LIE
BUT DEFINITELY AMIEWTION.
HOW WILL SHE EXPLAIN WELL WE